[Music]
today on the channel we will be
discussing the greatest and most
effective military forces
of the dune universe as i've stated
before
most combat in dune was hand to hand
based the presence of holtzman-based
shield technology brought the necessity
for limited use of lasegon technology
lasegun blasts produced nuclear
reactions when they came into contact
with shields
which would of course be devastating to
fighters on both sides
and likely cause even further damage to
the worlds being fought on
such weapons were still used however but
only in specific circumstances
the ability to subjugate or keep peace
in a galactic society required military
forces
there are several different galactic
military forces that came into power at
different times during the dune
universe's timeline
i will be listing the ones that i
consider to be the most significant
here sardikar was the name given to the
house carino's
imperial fighting forces from a young
age sartikar were trained on the
unforgiving world of seleucid secundus
much like life on arrakis life on
seleucid secundus
was hard the world pushed its
inhabitants to their extremes
seleucid secundus became the training
place of the sardikar once the royal
house carino moved from the world
to the world kaitain the planet salusis
had been depleted and ruined due to the
decadence and misuse
during the time in which house carino
resided there
it would eventually come to be known as
a prison planet
the sardikar soldiers were feared
throughout the empire
and widely thought to be the greatest
warriors during the time of the padesha
emperor shaddam iv they would eventually
however come to be defeated by the
fremen
during the battle of arakin on planet
dune
the sardukar were not the only ones to
call seleucid sekanda's home
however the zinsuni wanderers also for a
time
had resided there the friman people had
to send it from the zen sunni wonderers
a tribe of people who moved from planet
to planet facing hardships and trials on
different worlds
they eventually came to settle upon
arrakis according to the dune
encyclopedia
in the year 7193 ag
eons before house atreides arrived upon
the world
the hardness of the world-shaped fremen
society
they lived lives of minimal wastefulness
above all
else water was precious to them for
there was hardly any natural water on
the planet since the coming of the great
desert worms life in the harsh deserts
of arrakis
also shaped more than exceptional combat
warriors
by the time house atreides came to
arrakis
the freeman had already secretly been
one of the greatest fighting forces in
the universe
considering their size and skills in
combat
once paul atreides joined the fremen and
introduced them to the bini jesuit
weirding way
as well as atreides battle training they
surpassed
even the imperial sardikar as i said the
freeman
led by paul atreides eventually defeated
the imperial sardakar
afterward they led a crusade throughout
the universe in the name of paul
atreides
60 billion humans died during the jihad
that won the atreides empire
ultimately still the freemen would
wither until they were no more than a
shadow of what they once were
the museum freeman of lato the second's
distant empire
merely acted out old friend ways but did
not truly live frim and lives
in the time of the god emperor the fish
speakers were lato the second's military
force
they were the most effective military
force of all time
lato's fish speakers were all female and
they served him without question
the conditioning of the fish speakers
was such that their loyalty for lato
greatly surpassed the loyalty that the
freeman held for their mua deep
fish speaker devotion to the god emperor
was absolute
the fish speakers kept order throughout
lato's empire
and did whatever he commanded no matter
how difficult
even the beni jesuit sisterhood were no
match
at the death of the god emperor the fish
speakers fell in line behind duncan
idaho
other than the god emperor himself
duncan had been the most consistent
figure
in nato's empire having been brought
back countless times
as a gola the fish speakers apparently
squandered the leftover wealth of latos
empire
eventually partnering with other groups
by the time the bini jesuit sisterhood
emerged as the main power in the old
empire
the fish speakers were of little
significance
one final group that must be mentioned
here are the honored matres
though they do not have a specific name
for their fighting forces
the honored matries were created during
the scattering
the remnants of the benny jesuit who
ventured out into the space
beyond latos empire and the remnants of
the fish speakers who did the same
combined something about the scattering
brought the necessity for the merging
of these two groups without the spice
melange however
they lost many of the bini jesuit powers
the substance they used to replace spice
also made them aggressive and extremely
deadly
once they returned out of the scattering
into the old empire
they laid waste to entire planets they
were furious to be defied by any
and they demanded obedience from all the
matres killed with their feet
their shoes were equipped with razor
sharp pointed tips
their combat skills outmatched those of
even the benny jesuit
this fact is acknowledged several times
in the book chapter house dune
the honored montre's aggressive and
rambunctious nature however
often leads them down a self-destructive
path
and these are the most prominent
examples of fighting forces within the
dune universe
the timeline of the dune series lasts
thousands of years
certain groups are more relevant at
different times
the dune series creates no illusion of a
bloodless galactic
empire the human desire for power
over others often leads to trouble on a
galactic scale
the quest for power leads to devastation
on a mass
level at nearly every point in the
history of the dune universe
the people of the imperium were
controlled through violence at the hand
of the dominating power of the time
hi it's me quinn and thank you guys so
much for watching my video if you
enjoyed the content make sure you
like and subscribe and you can also
follow me on twitter if you want to help
me spread my reach as a content creator
and also if you would like to support
this channel you can click the paypal
link in the description to make a
one-time donation
or you can make a monthly donation on
patreon
thank you guys so much